ZDF heute live herzlich willkommen ein
Video aus Moskau sorgt für Aufsehen und
viele fragen sich nicht nur wie konnte
eine Drohne offenbar trotz aller
Luftverteidigung bis zum Kreml fliegen
sondern auch wer steckt dahinter und
welche Folgen hat das jetzt das
russische Präsidialamt teilt mit in der
Nacht sein zwei ukrainische Drohnen über
dem Kreml in Moskau abgeschossen worden
man werte das als geplanten
Terrorangriff
unsere Korrespondentin für Bega ist uns
aus Moskau zugeschaltet für was sagt der
Kreml noch dazu
also nach diesem offiziellen Statement
von heute Mittag gab es keine weiteren
Details demnach Handel soll es sich also
um zwei Drohnen gehandelt haben die vom
Militär und von Sicherheitskräften
unschädlich gemacht wurden dabei soll
nichts zu Schaden gekommen sein und auch
niemand verletzt worden sein
der Kreml sagt weiterhin in seinem
direkt im ersten Satz seines Statements
macht er Kiew dafür verantwortlich und
behält sich Vergeltungsmaßnahmen vor
über die noch entschieden werden soll
war denn das Leben von Präsident Putin
in Gefahr
nein Präsident Putin hat sich zum
Zeitpunkt dieser Vorfälle gar nicht im
Kreml aufgehalten aus seiner
Pressestelle heißt es heute die Drohnen
hätten auch seinen Arbeitstag heute
nicht beeinflusst und trotzdem wertet
der Kreml diese Angriffe eben auf
Angriffe als Angriffe auf Vladimir
Putins leben
nun ist in wenigen Tagen in Moskau ein
besonderer Tag am 09.05 findet die große
Parade anlässlich des Sieges über Nazi
Deutschland 1945 statt welche Folgen hat
dieser Vorfall jetzt so kurz vor dieser
sehr großen Veranstaltung
das ist im Moment noch nicht ganz klar
der Moskauer Bürgermeister ist der
gestern der hat heute jedenfalls nach
bekannt werden dieser Vorfälle ein
allgemeines drohnenverbot für die
Hauptstadt bekannt gegeben dazu muss man
vielleicht wissen dass es auch vor
diesem Verbot schon sehr restriktive
Gesetze gab was drohnenflüge in Moskau
angeht und ähm es eigentlich unmöglich
war eine Genehmigung dafür zu bekommen
es wird heute beteuert dass die Parade
zum sogenannten Tag des Sieges am 9 mai
stattfinden soll in anderen Städten
allerdings vor allem in solchen die sich
in der Grenznähe zu Ukraine befinden
wurden die Paraden bereits aus
Sicherheitsgründen abgesagt
vielen Dank für Bedarf für den Moment
nach Moskau für diese ersten
Einschätzungen zu diesem Vorfall und das
wirft natürlich viele Fragen auf die
Frage vor allem wer steckt dahinter und
dann gehen die russischen
Anschuldigungen wie gehört direkt nach
Kiew direkt in die Ukraine und es gab
eine erste Reaktion der ukrainische
Präsident selenski hat am Rande eines
Besuchs in Finnland die russischen
Anschuldigungen zurückgewiesen Zitat wir
greifen Putin oder Moskau nicht an wir
kämpfen auf unserem Gebiet
sprechen wir über all das mit dem
Russland Experten und Militärexperten
Nico lange der uns zugeschaltet ist Herr
Lange es gibt viele Spekulationen wir
haben gerade gehört wie die russischen
Reaktionen darauf sind was sind ihre
Informationen dazu
es gibt ja Videoaufnahmen aus der Nacht
bei denen man sehen kann dass zwei
Drohnen das Dach dieses Gebäudes im
Kreml angeflogen haben und dann offenbar
von dort vorhandenen Abwehrsystemen
offensichtlich Elektro magnetischen
Abwehrsystemen zerstört worden sind man
sieht nicht woher die Drohnen kamen also
sie kamen aus östlicher Richtung sie kam
jetzt nicht aus südöstlicher Richtung
aus der Ukraine und man sieht nicht wo
sie gestartet worden sind und man kann
auch den Typ der Drohnen in diesem
Videos nicht wirklich erkennen und
bisher konnte das auch niemand zuordnen
es ist bemerkenswert das Russland 12
Stunden lang diesen Angriff offenbar
geheim gehalten hat und dann mit einer
Veröffentlichung der Videos und mit
einer sofortigen Zuordnung zu Ukraine
reagiert hat aber bisher keine Angaben
macht auf welcher Grundlage eigentlich
diese Drohnen der Ukraine zuordnet
worden sind das legt die Vermutung nah
oder die Spekulation nah dass es eine
vollflächig Aktion sein könnte ein User
oder eine Userin namens Lea David fragt
über Youtube oder sagt über Youtube das
waren die Russen selbst was sagen sie
denn dazu
es wird ja bei vielen Ereignissen sofort
spekuliert oder behauptet dass es da um
Forex Operationen gehen könnte ich muss
ehrlich sagen ich kann zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt nicht erkennen welchen Sinn
denn eine russische Force black
Operation in dieser Art und Weise haben
sollte denn die Bilder die um die Welt
gehen heute die global gesendet werden
sind Bilder die extrem peinlich sind für
Wladimir Putin der drei Tage benötigen
wollte um kieft zu erobern und jetzt
Drohnen auf das Dach seiner eigenen
Residenz im Kreml geschossen bekommt
also ich kann einfach nicht erkennen
welcher wozu dieser Vorwand einer Volks
black Operation dienen sollte aber
gleichzeitig weiß man nicht wann ist die
Ukraine oder z.B Akteure von der Ukraine
gesteuert die von Moskau aus diese
Drohnen gestartet haben gibt es
Zusammenhänge in Russland das z.B Putin
Gegner oder Kräfte die im Streit
zwischen privaten Militärfirmen und den
verteilungsministerium eine Rolle
spielen daran beteiligt waren also das
ist alles zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt noch
unklar ich wäre vorsichtig mit der
sofortigen klaren Aussage das muss auf
jeden Fall eine falzschneck-operation
gewesen sein weil ich eben nicht
erkennen kann welchen Sinn eine solche
Operation haben sollte was halten Sie
denn von der Theorie dass es sich um
russische Hardliner handelt die Putin
damit quasi zu einem richtigen Krieg
gegen die Ukraine zwingen wollen und
einem einen Vergeltungsschlag damit
provozieren wollen
das kann man zumindest nicht völlig
ausschließen ich habe ja auf den
laufenden Streit zwischen privaten
Militärfirmen wieder Firma Wagner und im
verteilungsministerium hingewiesen und
Putin ist ja schon länger von sehr
extrem nationalistischen Kräften unter
Druck und die haben ja auch sofort
gefordert jetzt muss aber eine
generalmobile machen stattfinden jetzt
muss sozusagen richtig und mit aller
Kraft Krieg gegen die Ukraine geführt
werden also auch das ist zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt nicht auszuschließen die
Reaktionen waren ja im Kreml aber
trotzdem eindeutig ist der Ukraine
zuzuordnen also muss man sich auch die
Frage stellen warum hat der Kreml
eigentlich Interesse daran sofort zu
entscheiden und öffentlich bekannt zu
geben dass es sich um die Ukraine
gehandelt haben muss
sehe hier kurz mal in die Chats und
stelle fest dass da auch viel spekuliert
wird genau die Frage stellt sich auch
Michael Nelles könnte die wagnergruppe
damit zu tun haben das haben sie gerade
angesprochen zu Frage woher die Drohnen
kommen ob es ukrainische Drohnen waren
kommt hier die Frage hatten die
Hoheitszeichen aufgemalt da gibt's viel
Spekulationen und Fragen dazu woher die
Drohnen kamen aber das bleibt im Moment
im Bereich der Spekulation dann sprechen
wir über die
Sorge des vergeltungsschlages gegen die
Ukraine und
die Frage auch im Zusammenhang damit was
mit der gegen Offensive ist der
ukrainischen die ja in den jetzigen
Tagen auch erwartet wird
also zunächst mal noch zu den Drohnen
es ist aus meiner Sicht sehr
unwahrscheinlich dass man als aus
russischer Perspektive diese Drohnen
gesehen hat und sie sozusagen bis zum
Kreml fliegen lassen hat möglicherweise
den ganzen Weg aus der Ukraine um sie
erst dort über dem Dach des Kreml dann
zu zerstören also das klingt sehr
unwahrscheinlich möglicherweise sind sie
aber gar nicht in der Ukraine oder
weiter weg sondern sogar im Moskau
gestartet worden das wird man sicherlich
in den nächsten Stunden oder Tagen
herausfinden was Vergeltungsschläge
betrifft muss man ehrlicherweise sagen
putinsmöglichkeiten für
Vergeltungsschläge sind extrem begrenzt
es ist eben nicht so dass Russland noch
ganz große Kräfte in der Reserve hätte
oder jetzt sonst was für Schläge gegen
hier durchführen könnte die die Vorräte
an Marschflugkörper sind mittlerweile
begrenzt und es steht eben eine
ukrainische Gegend Offensive bevor man
die militärischen Ressourcen ja benötigt
um das eroberte Gebiet abzusichern und
dem erwarteten ukrainischen Gegenangriff
Stand zu halten sicherlich wird verbal
jetzt sehr stark
zurückgeschossen werden da hat ja auch
schon der Sprecher und andere haben ja
schon sehr starke Äußerungen gemacht
aber die militärischen Möglichkeiten für
Vergeltungsschläge sind extrem begrenzt
ein
Youtube-User namens Sascha para kennings
fragt der Krieg soll ja in Moskau nicht
so sehr präsent sein könnte er dadurch
Unterstützung suchen
diese Bilder lassen sich auf jeden Fall
nicht verheimlichen
und auch die Russen wissen ja dass der
Krieg nicht gut läuft und es ist
natürlich angesichts solcher Bilder für
Putin und für das Propaganda System noch
viel schwieriger zu sagen dass alles in
Ordnung alles läuft noch Plan bekommen
voran und wir machen hier meine schöne
Siegesfeier am 9 mai also das ist schon
jetzt eine große eine große Peinlichkeit
die auch schwer sein wird irgendwie zu
erklären oder zu rechtfertigen
ich würde gerne noch auf die Bilder die
wir gerade gesehen haben noch mal
dezidiert eingehen und wenn man genau
hinguckt wenn man sich die Aufnahmen
anguckt von denen ist ja
erstaunlicherweise auch aus
verschiedenen Perspektiven Aufnahmen
gibt auch das ist ja durchaus
interessant zu sehen aber wenn man da
genau hinguckt dann sieht man zwei
Menschen die offenbar auf der linken
Seite dieser Kuppel auf dem Dach nach
oben laufen auch das ist natürlich
Spekulation hat lange aber
Sicherheitsleute werden nicht auf dem
Dach sein um dort eine Drohne abzufangen
haben Sie irgendeine Theorie was ist
damit auf sich haben könnte
es gab ja ab in der Zeit zwischen nach 2
Uhr bis 3 Uhr
Drohnen die auf den Gremmel zugeflogen
sind und ich erkläre mir die Bilder so
dass diese Menschen auf dem Dach waren
nachdem die erste Drohne über diesen
Dach zerstört wurde und dann sozusagen
jetzt gefilmt worden als die zweite
Drohne zum kremme geflogen ist
das äh halte ich für die plausibelste
Erklärung für diese Bilder was die
Bilder selbst anbetrifft das kann ja ein
Grund sein warum der Kreml sich dazu
entschlossen hat diese Bilder selbst zu
veröffentlichen eine Erklärung abzugeben
weil rund um den Roten Platz um den
Kreml sehr sehr viele
Überwachungskameras da sind auch
Überwachungskameras zum Beispiel von
privaten Geschäften von Gebäuden und was
ich so ein Drohnenangriff der wo es auch
Explosion gegeben hat doch nicht
dauerhaft geheim halten lässt ich halte
es für sehr wahrscheinlich dass man sich
deswegen entschieden hat die Dinge zu
kommunizieren und der Geschichte selbst
einen Rahmen zu geben bevor ungeordnet
Handyvideos oder andere Videos von
Überwachungskameras in die
Öffentlichkeit gelangen und der Kreml
dann weniger Möglichkeiten hat die Story
zu steuern lassen Sie uns noch mal
darüber reden wie das überhaupt gelungen
ist dass diese Drohnen so weit gekommen
sind wo auch immer sie jetzt herkamen
aber ein User fragt wenn das stimmt dass
die Drohne eben bis nach Moskau kam sagt
dass viel über das russische Militär aus
wie ist das zu erklären dass diese
Drohnen überhaupt bis dorthin gelangt
sind
es ist fraglich aus meiner Sicht sind
diese Drohnen den ganzen Weg aus der
Ukraine geflogen oder sind sie in der
Nähe von Moskau oder möglicherweise
sogar
gestartet worden das kann man zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt noch nicht beurteilen
möglicherweise wird das in den nächsten
Stunden und Tagen aufgeklärt werden und
und dann wiederum entschuldigung ich als
nicht drohnenexpertin muss ja noch mal
nachfragen dann wiederum könnte kein
Luftabwehrsystem greifen sozusagen wenn
vor Ort deine Drohne in die Höhe steigt
dann ist das eine andere Bedrohungslage
für dieses Thema als wenn das quasi von
von weiter weg kommt
also das macht grundsätzlich erstmal
einen Unterschied wenn sie nach der
russischen Luftverteidigung fragen da
muss man schon konstatieren es gab ja
auch schon Drohnenangriffe auf die
Luftwaffenbasis zum Beispiel in Engels
wo die strategische Bombe Flotte
stationiert ist es gab Drohnen die
andere wichtige strategische Orte in
Russland angegriffen haben also das
scheint mit der russischen
Luftverteidigung ganz eindeutig was
nicht in Ordnung zu sein oder sie
scheint riesige Lücken zu haben oder
Unaufmerksamkeiten oder man hat die
Ressourcen alle irgendwo im Don Bass
oder in der Ostukraine verwendet und
viele Objekte in Russland scheinen
ungeschützt zu sein das haben wir in der
Vergangenheit schon gesehen was die
drohnenabwehr betrifft
am Kreml und rund um den Kreml
kann ich natürlich sozusagen zu Details
dazu nicht sagen kann aber nur vermuten
dass es doch so sein müsste dass da eine
ständige Überwachung stattfindet und der
schon seit einiger Zeit auch immer
wieder über Flugverbote gesprochen wurde
das zumindest bemerkenswert dass die
Drohnen nicht schon abgefangen wurden
oder zerstört wurden bevor sie zu diesem
Dach im Gelände des Kremls gelangt sind
das kann aber auch eine Schwäche in den
Abwehrsystem sein und Aufmerksamkeit ist
ja auch mitten in der Nacht passiert
zwischen zwei und 3 Uhr wie gesagt egal
welcher Fall es war von dem
beschriebenen es ist extrem peinlich für
diejenigen die da immer so groß und
stark auftreten aus den russischen
Sicherheitsbehörden und ist extrem
peinlich für Putin selbst
lange zwei Fragen würde ich gerne noch
an Sie stellen Julian schuma fragt über
Youtube hätten Drohnen dieser Größe denn
so weit beurteilbar überhaupt
ernsthaften Schaden anstellen können in
so einem riesigen Komplex wie dem Kreml
oder ist das eher als Warnung oder macht
Demonstration zu verstehen
diese Art von Drohnenangriff setzt auf
einen psychologischen Effekt also ist
aus meiner Sicht überhaupt nicht
erwartbar dass diese Drohnen einen
massiven Schaden anrichten und wir
sollten jetzt auch nicht unbedingt die
russischen Meldungen oder
einordnungsversuche wiederholen das
seinen Anschlag auf Putins Leben gewesen
das ist glaube ich überhaupt nicht das
Ziel gewesen dieses Drohnenangriff
sondern das Ziel des Drohnen Angriffs
ist den Kreml zu blamieren und das ist
ja auch genug
dann eine letzte Frage Herr Lange
inwiefern beeinflusst dieser Vorfall den
Krieg Russland gegen die Ukraine
aus meiner Sicht hat das für das direkte
Geschehen im Krieg keinen Einfluss wir
werden sehen ob Russland jetzt zu
Vergeltungsmaßnahmen greift die
militärisch glaube ich keinen
Unterschied machen können also zivile
Städte werden jede Nacht beschossen
Raketenangriffe hat es in der
Vergangenheit immer wieder gegeben
russland hat nicht mehr so viele
Marschflugkörper und hat auch begrenzte
Möglichkeiten jetzt da eine Vergeltung
zu üben wenn es aber zu einer
emotionalen Überreaktion kommt das
Russland jetzt militärische Ressourcen
verwendet für Vergeltungsschläge die ist
eigentlich bräuchte um gegen die
ukrainische gegen Offensive sich
aufzustellen könnte das Russland
Schwächen auf jeden Fall gibt es im
psychologischen Effekt auf die
russischen Kräfte und auf Russland
insgesamt weil das schon eine sehr
starke symbolische Verletzung ist genau
über dem Dach des Krems diese Explosion
zu sehen also da wird Russland auf jeden
Fall nicht gestärkt dadurch
sagt der Russland Experte Nico lange
vielen Dank dass Sie bei uns zu Gast im
Stream waren danke schön für ihre
Einschätzungen
und an dieser Stelle auch wieder vielen
Dank für Ihre und eure Fragen und
Kommentare und der Hinweis dass wir
heute noch einen Stream machen und zwar
zur Rolle der Wagner Söldner das war ja
auch jetzt hier immer eine Frage
inwiefern die vielleicht auch mit diesem
Anschlag oder mit diesen Drohnen
Angriffen etwas zu tun haben könnten und
wer die Wagner sollten sind wo sie in
der Welt eingesetzt werden wer dahinter
steckt das besprechen wir in einem
Stream dazu herzliche Einladung und ich
sage bis gleich tschüss